i would say it's clear we need to work
more
on getting the message out and being
very clear now is not the time to come
uh there is uh the majority of people
who come to the border are turned away
white house press secretary gensake
addressing the escalating crisis
along the southern border as customs and
border protection is on track to surpass
the number of detentions
from last year this after the trump
administration dramatically decreased
illegal immigration in its final year
joining us now is mark morgan former
acting cbp commissioner i'm reminded
uh mark that you know there were times
when at a white house
you you want to talk about uh your
education proposal
but something else it keeps getting in
the way and i
sense a little bit of frustration from
the white house that they keep being
asked
about immigration when they would much
rather talk about covid
dana and this is what they get i think
president trump said it best
during the cpac speech this is a
self-inflicted wound that they brought
up on themselves
and look the numbers let's talk about
february numbers we're going to look at
over a hundred thousand
individuals uh that illegally entered in
the month of february
and the former secretary jay johnson
when he was referring to a thousand
he was talking about a thousand
apprehensions per day i worked for him
as chief of border troll
trust me if we had over a thousand
apprehensions in a single day it was a
bad day
we're looking at now getting close to
five thousand
apprehensions a day and they still
refuse to say it's a crisis
and since january dana they've released
over 11 000
illegal aliens at bus stations and
shelters locally
and they're busting further into the
united states and they refuse to say
it's a crisis did you see the new york
times they called these facilities
jail-like facilities
did you catch that and did you think
about the distinction with all the heat
that came in on the trump team
um for the the cages comments go ahead
yeah bill i i mean the hypocrisy i mean
we're seeing level after
level of hypocrisy again under trump
these
same facilities i was there the same
facilities were inhumane and immoral
and now the facilities are being built
some by the same vendors are now somehow
essential and they're humane the
hypocrisy but but here's what's more
important though
it's how they're using the facilities
look he dismantled every almost every
effective tool
replace it with nothing and now what
they're doing on our borders now these
facilities they're using them as
reception centers
the mandate has been to get release them
and process them and release them as
fast as possible
and on the back end preventing ice from
deporting them so we have reception
centers on the front end
and a sanctuary country on the back end
that's where we're at right now
what do you hear from the people that
you used to work with
that worked under you that are trying to
process i'm trying to get my head around
how do you
deal with 5000 apprehensions a day just
physically
it's tough look we're i think we're the
most one of the most powerful nations in
the world
and we cannot deal with a hundred
thousand illegal immigrants
entering our border every single month
almost five thousand
a day right now at one point in 2020 we
had less than 500 people in in our
custody because of the
trump policies right now dana they have
over 6
000 in custody in the middle of a global
pandemic and like you said
half of those over 3 000 are
unaccompanied kids because the system is
already overwhelmed
hhs doesn't have the facilities we've
been here before
we experienced this in 2019 we told the
bite administration if they did what
they're doing
this is what happened and they ignored
us but this is exactly what they want to
do
quickly i would say it's clear we need
to work more on getting the message out
of being very clear
now is not the time to come how do you
lessen the flow now sir
you don't look look their message the
bite administration has actually
actually been
crystal clear and their message is our
borders are open
and come on in and when you do we're
going to release you into the united
states
and then not deport you lawfully so you
can remain here illegally forever
and now to tell the smugglers and the
cartels and the migrants with cells
pretty please don't come
yet it's a it's a joke bill it's absurd
well mark morgan thank you sarah we
will be in touch again later in the week